Y por supuesto la economía protagonista
en todo este conflicto Jorge Hurtado
conmigo en el estudio Jorge continúan
las sanciones y las restricciones contra
Rusia Así es Raúl y bueno es que ahora
es el Banco Mundial el que decidió
suspender todas sus actividades no solo
en Rusia sino también en velarruz el
anuncio se da un día después de que el
presidente del Banco Mundial Davis
malpas dijera que preparan un paquete de
asistencia de emergencia de 3000
millones de dólares para Ucrania el
Banco Mundial informó que su último
proyecto aprobado en vela rusa es de
mediados de 2020 de la Rush es conocido
como un Aliado de Moscú ya facilitado
inclusive el tránsito de militares rusos
hacia Ucrania en un comunicado conjunto
con la directora gerente del fondo
monetario internacional cristalina yor
lleva el Banco Mundial advertido de los
efectos económicos significativos en
otros países del conflicto y las
sanciones impuestas a Rusia entre los
defectos citaron Inclusive la subida de
los precios de las materias primas y el
de una inflación acelerada y como era de
esperarse el impacto de estas sanciones
económicas comienza no anotarse en Rusia
Así es Y es que según exclusiva de la
agencia router hay cientos de empresas
que están buscando refugio en bancos
chinos allá en Rusia según un ejecutivo
de un banco Estatal chino en Rusia en
los últimos días entre 200 y 300
empresas y han puesto en contacto con
ellos queriendo abrir nuevas cuentas el
argumento de las empresas que en su
mayoría hacia el negocios con china es
que esperan que aumenten las
transacciones en yuanes por parte de
dichas empresas occidente Busca Aguilar
a Rusia el sistema financiero mundial
empujando empujando las empresas
internacionales a detener sus ventas por
su parte china mostrado su posición a
las sanciones calificándola de
ineficiente se insistiendo En qué
mantendrá los intercambios económicos y
comerciales con Rusia hay muchas más
noticias en torno a ese conflicto
comenzamos con el petróleo los precios
del petróleo continúan al alza los
futuros del crudo subieron hasta 119,84
barril el máximo de mayo de 2012 el
aumento fue el 6,85 o un 6,1% alguno de
experto señalan que el precio podría
llegar hasta los 130 $ Raúl la agencia
de calificación crediticia Fish y muro y
rebajaron la calificación de Rusia en
seis escalones hasta situarla en grados
especulativo la rebaja coloca ahora
Rusia a la par de Naciones como Nigeria
y Bolivia y las aerolíneas europeas y le
estadounidense boing anunciaron la
suspensión de sus operaciones en Moscú y
la detención de sus trabajos de
mantenimientos soporte técnico para las
aerolíneas rusas
IKEA la empresa minorista de muebles y
electrodomésticos suspendió sus
actividades en Rusia y de la Rusia la
decisión Deja unos 15,000 empleados
afectados
bueno Jorge y la cancelación del
polémico gasoducto norson 2 trae
posiciones encontradas esto en un
pequeño pueblo de Alemania Así es bueno
Luego de que Alemania canceló la
certificación de este proyecto ante la
negativa Moscú de retirar sus tropas de
la frontera con Ucrania una semana
después la empresa Se declaró insolvente
y despidió a 106 trabajadores en la
localidad costera alemana del dumming
donde el gasoducto llega a la costa
muchos residentes albergan la esperanza
del desarrollo que podría generar el
gasoducto Aunque para otros el proyecto
fue un error escuchamos
creo que es correcto de tener
dos por la sencilla razón de que nuestra
dependencia de Rusia es demasiado
grandes
y creo que la República Federal de
Alemania no debería hacerse dependiente
de Rusia
es mucho dinero que se esfuma y quién
sabe lo que pasará todo es terrible con
Rusia pero aún así de tenerlo ahora no
creo que sea bueno que lo detengamos
ahora
empezamos Raúl con las acciones
asiáticas que operaron mixtas tomando
como referencia el rebote de Wall Street
tras los comentarios del presidente de
la reserva Federal German Powell sobre
la subida de los tipos de interés las
acciones europeas que dieron por el
impacto de las sanciones contra Rusia y
pese al repunte de los precios de las
materias primas Jorge gracias por toda
la información económica nos vemos más
adelante con más economía por supuesto
vamos a ver nuestro reportaje del día
[Música]